director the art director instead
directors not someone your heart or redo
your living room
they don't redo they recreate the world
and as far as they're concerned the past
is never gone and countries aren't far
away miles away to honor these creative
minds and hearts for the journeys
they've given us here to present the
award for best art director is a fellow
who as they say was finally discovered
by Hollywood last year and a very
talented lady who was finally discovered
by Hollywood this year Paul Winfield and
Miss Sylvia Sidney
the nominees for best achievement in art
direction are brother Sun sister Lu
Lorenzo bonds R&D no and Gianna quattron
scent aggression Carmelo patronum the
exorcism bill malli
set decoration Jerry Wonderlic the sting
henry Bumstead decoration James May Tom
Sawyer Philip Jeffries set decoration
Robert Vesco
the way we were Steven Grimes set
decoration William Carey and the winner
is the winners are Henry bump stood for
the state and for set decoration James
came
I'd like to thank the members of the
Academy George Roy hill and all the
people associated with the sting without
their help I wouldn't be here tonight
thank you very very much
thank you very very much
first of all mum and dad then George and
bummy and all of the guys that worked
with me on the sting and of course you
guys at the academy thank you very much